Deutschen Bundestag ab morgen wird im
Hohen Hause debattiert alle
Politikbereiche nacheinander Weg das
wird sicher eine spannende Veranstaltung
am morgenvormittag und heute werden wird
diese Debatte wird diese Sitzungswoche
zum Haushalt vorbereitet in den
Fraktionen journalistisch begleitet von
meinem Kollegen er hat schärfer er hat
wie wir erwarten ja gleich
Stellungnahmen unter anderem von
Friedrich Merz und von der Union
neben den anderen Politikfeldern die
diese Woche debattiert werden da spielt
ja so ein bisschen mit über allem diese
Diskussion um das sogenannte Bürgergeld
gibt es denn da jetzt Bewegung denn im
Laufe dieser Woche muss man sich ja
irgendwie einigen wenn das noch was
werden soll
[Musik]
manche sagen so Hans Werner manche sagen
so erste machen schon Vorschläge was man
machen kann und wo sie bei den
Verhandlungen den anderen Entgegenkommen
wollen das stößt dann auf
unterschiedlich große Begeisterung weil
die Gespräche laufen nämlich nach wie
vor noch hinter den Kulissen im Moment
am Mittwoch wird dann offiziell auch am
Abend ab ca 19 Uhr so heißt es im
Vermittlungsausschuss zwischen Bundestag
und Bundesrat richtig verhandelt dann
hoffen wir alle dass ein Ergebnis kommt
jedenfalls alle aus der Koalition das
ist ein Ergebnis gibt dass es noch eine
Verabschiedung des Bürgergeldes in
diesem Jahr idealerweise noch in dieser
Woche möglich macht damit es nämlich zum
ersten Januar in allen seinen Teilen in
Kraft treten kann auch wenn manche
Bereiche ohne hinschauen erst mit etwas
Verspätung stattfinden sollen es gibt ja
es geht ja nicht nur um die umstrittenen
Themen die immer wieder angesprochen
werden um die Erhöhung der Regelsätze da
gibt sogar eine relativ große Einigkeit
auch in der Union ist man dafür diese
Regelsätze zu erhöhen und aber es gibt
andere Bereiche wo sich die Koalition
über hat das hartz-iv-modell das
bisherige abzulösen eben durch dieses
Bürgergeld und das ist aus Sicht der
Koalition insbesondere SPD natürlich
damit verknüpft dass beispielsweise
Sachen wie Sanktionen gegen Arbeit
suchende und Bürgergeld Empfänger dann
anders gewichtet werden anders
eingestuft werden als das bislang der
Fall gewesen ist auch das sogenannte
Schonvermögen also das angesparte was
Menschen haben wenn sie sich im
arbeitslos melden auch da gibt es die
Diskussion darüber wo die Union
kritisiert das sei zu hoch das müsste
niedriger angesetzt werden die Sanktion
sagt die Union führten dazu dass nicht
mehr gefordert sondern nur noch
gefördert wird da ist die Koalition
gänzlich andere Auffassung aber überall
dem steht ja unter anderem das große
Ziel und das ist interessanterweise
überhaupt nicht umstritten nämlich die
Beschäftigten die sich arbeitslos
gemeldet damals wo los melden muss
mussten zu entweder zu qualifizieren
insbesondere für Langzeitarbeitslose um
zu schulen mit dem großen Ziel
wieder in Arbeit kommen denn wir haben
ja das bekanntermaßen einen großen
Fachkräftemangel in Deutschland wir
haben viele Bereiche nicht besetzt also
müssten die so ist die Idee die Mut nach
Arbeit suchen eigentlich besser
ausgebildet werden um diese
Arbeitsplätze dann wieder besetzen zu
können dieser Punkt ist weder von
der bei der Union gar nicht umstritten
sondern man hat sich jetzt fest geharkt
und intensiv damit beschäftigt die Frage
sehr Sanktionen zu erörtern und das
Schonvermögens eine der Schlagzeilen die
bei dieser Gelegenheit ja immer im
Umlauf sind ist dass diejenigen die
nicht arbeiten hier also beispielsweise
beziehen unter Umständen weil sie auch
noch andere Sozialleistungen dazu
bekommen können wenn sie das nachweisen
können besser darstellen als Menschen
die arbeiten das ist umstritten sogar
sehr umstritten als Studien gibt die
sagen dass das nicht der Fall ist dass
man auf jeden Fall besser dran ist wenn
man arbeitet als wenn man nicht arbeitet
da hat ihn in den vergangenen Wochen
einen ziemlicher in eine ziemliche
Debatte darum getobt und wie gesagt das
ganze jetzt auf der Zielgerade hoffen
jedenfalls alle Beteiligen Beteiligten
dass das ganze dann auch
zu einem Abschluss gebracht wird ja da
gab es ja auch ordentlich Polemiken zu
diesem Thema die zwischen den ich sag
jetzt mal beiden Lagern ausgetauscht
worden sind also so viel zu diesem Thema
Bürgergeld was da in den
Vermittlungsausschuss diskutiert wird
und vorher sicher schon zwischen den
beiden unterschiedlichen Lagern schauen
wir auf andere Politikfelder er hat die
diese Woche möglicherweise im Rahmen
dieser Haushaltsdebatte eine größere
Rolle spielen werden ich meine
Klimaschutzpolitik wegen dieser
Konferenz in Sharm el Sheikh in Ägypten
ist ja erst gestern zu Ende gegangen
könnte ich mir vorstellen ist ein großes
Thema
Verteidigungspolitik die sogenannte
zeitenwände erscheinen ist ja auch nicht
so richtig voran zu gehen jedenfalls
nicht so wie man sich das vorgestellt
hat was sind aus ihrer Sicht die
spannendsten Diskussionen diese Woche
erwarten können
nein das wäre natürlich traditionell
traditionell die generalddebatte sein an
dir an diesem Mittwoch wenn der
Bundeskanzler sich den Abgeordneten
stellt und die Opposition darauf
erwidert da wird ja bekanntermaßen die
Politik dieser Ampelkoalition dann
insgesamt in Frage gestellt werden von
der Opposition und dann gilt es sich zu
verteidigen und insofern ist natürlich
der Mittwoch der entscheidende Tag immer
in einer solchen haushaltswoche was das
öffentliche die öffentliche
Auseinandersetzung zumindest angeht aber
sie haben sie haben völlig rechtlich
auch die anderen Themen werden eine
große Rolle spielen wir haben ja hier
unter anderem das Thema Wirtschaft und
Klimaschutz sein am Freitag auf der
Tagesordnung glaube ich morgen zum neuen
da wird man sicherlich das eine oder
andere auch noch mal diskutieren rund um
das Thema um den um die Welt
Klimakonferenz das habe ich ein Signal
bekommen dass es sich offenbar mit denen
auf die wir gerade seit geraumer Zeit
schon warten nämlich Friedrich Merzig
Vorsitzenden der Unionsfraktion und
seinen ersten Stellvertreter Alexander
Dobrind doch irgendwie massiver
verzögert als wir das gehofft haben nein
und jetzt kriege ich das Gegenteil
signalisiert deswegen muss ich jetzt
ganz schnell wieder zurückrudern und
bereite sie vor auf diese beiden die
jetzt doch offensichtlich auf dem Weg
sind zu den beiden Pulten direkt hinter
mir die sind ja auch schon prima
ausgeleuchtet seit geraumer Zeit und
dann werden wir jetzt auch noch mal
hören ob die Themen die Sie Hans Werner
eben angesprochen haben auch hier noch
mal thematisiert werden auf jeden Fall
bin ich sicher dass es noch ein zwei
Worte zum Thema Bürgergeld geben wird
möglicherweise auch zur
Weltklimakonferenz auch wenn man da aus
den vergangenen Tagen jetzt speziell zu
diesem Bereich aus der Union ehrlich
gesagt eher weniger gehört hat aber das
Bürgergeld spielt sicher eine Rolle und
jetzt geht's los hier hinter mir
ja meine Damen und Herren herzlich
willkommen wir
stehen am Anfang der haushaltswoche
zur Beratung der zweiten und dritten in
der zweiten und dritten Lesung des
Bundeshaushaltes
das Haushaltsjahr 2022 wird abschließend
mit einer
nie dagewesenen Rekordverschuldung des
Bundes die bei rund 500 Milliarden Euro
liegen wird einschließlich aller
Verpflichtungsermächtigungen die in den
nächsten Jahre bereits jetzt eingegangen
werden und damit auch gegen ganz
fundamentale Grundsätze der
Haushaltsführung des bundesverstoßen
unter anderem das sogenannte
jährlichkeitsprinzip das Einnahmen und
Ausgaben im selben Haushaltsjahr
getätigt werden müssen nur damit sie mal
ein Gefühl dafür bekommen was in diesem
Jahr geschieht diese Bundesregierung
nimmt in einem Jahr mehr Schulden auf
als Bund Länder Gemeinden und
Sozialversicherung in den Jahren von
1949 bis 1990 aufgenommen haben also das
was alle staatlichen Instanzen zu
beginnen der Existenz der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland in 40 Jahren an Schulden
aufgenommen haben wird allein in diesem
Jahr allein vom Bund aufgenommen
das zeigt in welcher dramatischen
Verfassungs sich die Staatsfinanzen
befinden wir werden über die Einzelpläne
im Laufe dieses Jahr in dieser Woche
sicherlich im Detail reden ich will nur
diese eine Bemerkung vorweg machen bevor
wir dann in die Haushaltsdebatte gehen
die dann morgen früh um 9 Uhr beginnt
wir haben ein zweites Thema in dieser
Woche am Mittwochabend wird zum ersten
Mal in dieser Wahlperiode der
Vermittlungsausschuss zusammentreten es
gibt keine Zustimmung des Bundesrates
für das sogenannte Bürgergeld der
Koalition am letzten Montag hat es in
einer Sondersitzung des Bundesrates die
erforderliche Mehrheit zur Zustimmung
für dieses Gesetz nicht gegeben
insbesondere die von der Union regierten
und mit regierten Länder haben dem
Gesetz nicht zugestimmt die
Bundesregierung hat dann den
Vermittlungsausschuss angerufen und
dieser Vermittlungsausschuss wird wie
gesagt nur morgen übermorgen Abend am
Mittwoch Abend das erste Mal
zusammentreten
die haben in den letzten Tagen einige
Gespräche formell informell geführt
nicht vor mir sondern informell geführt
mit Vertretern der Koalition ich kann
Ihnen sagen dass die unionsseite
Bundestagsfraktion und
unionsregierte und mitregierte Länder
eine sehr klare Vorstellung haben wie es
möglicherweise zu einem Kompromiss
kommen könnte wenn es denn ein
erfolgreiches
vermittlungsausschussverfahren geben
sollte für uns steht im Vordergrund dass
das Prinzip Fördern und Fordern aufrecht
erhalten wird wir sind nicht der Meinung
dass mit diesem Bürgergeld diesen
sogenannten Bürgergeld das schon in
seiner Bezeichnung auf einen völlig
falschen Weg führt der Einstieg in ein
bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen genommen
werden sollte aber das genau suggeriert
ja schon der Titel und auch der Inhalt
so weit er bisher von der Koalition
festgelegt worden ist
das heißt im Klartext wenn die Koalition
bereit ist auf diese sogenannte
vertrauenszeit zu verzichten wenn die
Koalition bereit ist vom ersten Tag der
leistungszahlung auch eine
Mitwirkungspflicht der Betroffenen zu
erwarten wenn die Koalition bereit ist
auch über die Dauer der Karenzzeit für
die nicht in Anspruchnahme eines eigenen
Vermögens und wenn die Dauer wenn die
Koalition bereit wäre auch über die Höhe
dieses sogenannten Schonvermögens mit
sich reden zu lassen dann wäre eine
Einigung aus unserer Sicht vorstellbar
dass setzt allerdings voraus dass die
Koalition wirklich an dieser
substanziellen Seite ihres Vorhabens
Abstriche macht ohne die Beibehaltung
des Prinzips fördern und fördern wird es
nach meiner Einschätzung eine Zustimmung
auch im Bundesrat
auf der unionsseite nicht geben wenn die
Koalition
schnell bereit ist sich diesen
Vorstellungen anzunähern dann kann es
eine schnelle Einigung geben ich bin
allerdings bis jetzt nicht davon
überzeugt dass das so sein wird es kommt
hinzu dass wir aus der Erfahrung die wir
mit der Koalition gemacht haben bei der
Abfassung des Sondervermögens des
sogenannten Sondervermögens für die
Bundeswehr im Frühjahr diesen Jahres nur
schlechte Erfahrung gemacht haben was
politische Zusagen betrifft es sind von
diesen Zusagen die wir im Zusammenhang
mit der Einführung des Sondervermögens
in das Grundgesetz bekommen haben keine
einzige eingehalten worden und deswegen
sind Markus Söder und ich uns für die
beiden Parteien einig und ich sage das
hier auch als Vorsitzender
Bundestagsfraktion auch in der
Bundestagsfraktion einig dass wir wenn
überhaupt eine Zustimmung nur dann
erteilen wenn wir
Gesetzestexte vor uns liegen haben die
dann auch auf beiden Seiten Bundes-
können das heißt politische Zusagen wir
machen das mal so sind schön und gut
aber sie sind nicht die Basis für eine
Zustimmung von uns sondern wir können
und werden nur zustimmen wenn wir
ausformulierte Gesetzestexte haben die
dann auch Gegenstand der Abstimmungen
gegebenenfalls im Bundestag und dem
Bundesrat sein werden
Alexander
ja sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
bei Hartz IV Bürgergeld reden wir
natürlich von
Langzeitarbeitslosigkeit mit dem Ziel
diese Langzeitarbeitslosigkeit zu
beenden die Menschen aus dieser
Langzeitarbeitslosigkeit
herauszuführen dieses Ziel wird mit dem
von der Ampel vorgeschlagenen
Gesetzentwurf ja nicht erfüllt das heißt
wir müssen genau dahin wie der kommen
dass wir Menschen aus dieser
Langzeitarbeitslosigkeit herausbringen
dazu braucht es auch den Mechanismus der
Sanktionen bisher sieht ja dieses Gesetz
vor dass es keine Sanktionen mehr gibt
wenn die Arbeitsaufnahme verweigert wird
das ist keine Sanktionen gibt wenn die
Sprachförderung verweigert wird das ist
auch keine Sanktionen mit gibt wenn
weiter Bildungsangebote nicht angenommen
werden damit führt man Menschen nicht
aus der Langzeitarbeitslosigkeit heraus
und damit zementiert man geradezu die
Langzeit Arbeitslosigkeit und deswegen
ist eines der entscheidendsten Punkte an
der Stelle dass hier wieder Sanktionen
vorgesehen werden um auch die
Möglichkeit zu eröffnen aus dieser
Situation eben der
Langzeitarbeitslosigkeit sich heraus zu
entwickeln fördern und fördern ist das
Grundprinzip dass dort genannt wird das
muss wieder hergestellt werden dann kann
man mit Alexander Dobrindt und davor
Friedrich Merz mit dem Thema der Woche
neben dem Bundeshaushalt 2023 hier in
Berlin im Bundestag nämlich den
Bürgergeld am Mittwoch im
Vermittlungsausschuss wenn alles gut
geht für alle Beteiligten dann am
Freitag Donnerstag oder Freitag noch mal
im Bundestag und auf jeden Fall am
Freitag dann im Bundesrat er sei
zuversichtlich und die Gespräche sein
auf einem guten Weg hat Rolf Mütze nicht
zu genau diesem Thema gesagt vor gut 12
Stunden und hier ist sein Statement das
aber auch über das Thema Bürgergeld
hinausgeht
wir werden morgen den Finanzminister
hören aber dann natürlich insbesondere
am Mittwoch die sogenannte größere Runde
das Bundeskanzlers und dann der
Fraktionsvorsitzenden wir sind sehr
zuversichtlich dass wir eine gute
haushaltswoche haben weil die
haushälteren und Haushälter insbesondere
aus den
Koalitionsfraktionen gut und auch
nochmal zielgerichtet gehandelt haben
wir haben noch mal 31 Milliarden Euro
insgesamt bewegt insbesondere für
wichtige öffentliche
Güter die wir auch zur Verfügung stellen
wollen in dieser Krisensituation wir
Sozialdemokraten Sozialdemokraten
konzentrieren uns natürlich auf die
Bereiche Arbeit wohnen Mobilität Bildung
alles das sind Dinge die wir auch mit
diesem Haushalt voranbringen auf der
anderen Seite wird auch in der
haushaltswoche relativ ungewöhnlich dann
auch noch in zweiter und dritter Lesung
das laut Gesetz verabschiedet wir haben
dann zusätzliche Einnahmen und wir
beginnen dann auch direkt in der
Verabredung damit wie Mobilität in den
nächsten Jahren durch die zusätzlichen
Einnahmen finanziert werden können bin
froh dass wenn der erste Lesung für
zusätzliche
Unterstützungsleistungen für Studierende
haben was insbesondere nicht nur
Studentinnen und Studentinnen sondern
auch Fachschüler betrifft 200 Euro
werden doch noch mal zusätzlich
mobilisiert und das
energiesicherungsgesetz soll eben in
dieser Krisensituation uns Sicherheit
geben dass wir auf dem Wärmemarkt mit
genügend dann auch letztlich
Energie unterstützt werden das sind also
die Dinge die uns in dieser Woche als
Mitglieder des Deutschen Bundestags
beschäftigen und das werden wir gleich
auch in der Fraktionssitzung besprechen
von einem zu schwimmenden lng-terminals
und mehr kosten wie sie das bewerten ob
man sich da verrechnet hat ob man das
irgendwie so stemmen kann was da
passiert ist und dann zum Thema
Bürgergeld wie der Moment der Stand ist
es soll ja ein Treffen geben die FDP hat
schon gesagt dass sie sich vorstellen
könnten die vertrauenszeit quasi zu
lassen ob das ein gangbarer Weg auch für
die SPD wäre in der Tat habe ich über
auch die zusätzlichen Mittel die für die
lng-terminals mobilisiert werden müssen
erst heute erfahren auch nicht
unmittelbaren aus den Häusern sondern
auch durch die mediale Begleitung
deswegen konnte ich mir auch noch kein
Bild und kein erschließen des Bild
machen dass ich manchmal auch mehr
Kosten ergeben gerade in einer solchen
Krisensituation das Wissen
private Haushalte für kleinere Projekte
das gilt natürlich auch für solche
großen Projekte wie für die LNG
Terminals wir brauchen die Terminals wir
wollen das eben auch auf der einen Seite
die gut gesicherten speichern ist eine
ganz wichtige Voraussetzung für diesen
Winter aber auch weiterhin befüllt
werden können so dass ich hoffe dass uns
insbesondere ein zuständiges Haus
auskömmlich Antwort geben wird in den
nächsten Stunden und Tagen und beim
Bürgergeld würde ich weiterhin dazu
raten wie ich das auch in der
vorvergangenen Woche getan haben nicht
Dinge auf der öffentlichen Bühne
auszubreiten sich schon gar nicht
aufzuplustern auch keine Hinweise zu
geben wo man was verhandeln kann was ich
Ihnen aber durchaus und ich glaube auch
verlässlich sagen kann ich glaube dass
wir auf einen guten Weg sind es finden
ja jetzt nicht Verhandlungen in dem
Sinne statt sondern die werden im
Vermittlungsausschuss geführt aber alles
das
was wir auch an Ideen und die habe ich
selbst auch einbringen können wird uns
dem Bürgergeld
wichtige Schritte näher bringen und das
ist auch wichtig nicht nur für
Transferleistungsempfänger sondern auch
für die Menschen die sich Sorgen um ihre
Arbeitsplätze in den nächsten Jahren
machen und da wollen wir mit dem
Bürgergeld auch ein Angebot machen vor
dem Hintergrund auch veränderter
Rahmenbedingungen damals zu Hartz IV
jetzt zu einem Bürgergeld wo wir einen
doch sehr entspannten Arbeitsmarkt haben
uns deswegen auf Bildungsfragen
konzentrieren wollen würden sie uns
verraten ob der Vorschlag von
Generalsekretär vom Generalsekretär der
FDP mit Ihnen abgestimmt war würden sie
so weit gehen
ich muss sagen dass der Generalsekretär
der FDP
nichts abstimmt mit uns das muss ja auch
nicht aber ich würde ihm schon wenn er
ein Ratschlag von mir erwünscht mit auf
den Weg geben dass in so sensiblen
Fragen man sich nicht vorher bereits
verkämpfen sollte das hilft allen
Verhandlungen und Verhandlungen nicht
was sagen sie das jetzt Manuel Neuer
doch ohne one love-binde auflaufen soll
sollte der DFB deutlicher politisch
Zeichen setzen den Katar ihrer Meinung
nach
also ich finde es gibt einen großen
Unterschied offensichtlich zwischen der
FIFA auf der einen Seite und mutigen
Spielern wie zum Beispiel die iranische
Nationalmannschaft die ja offensichtlich
nicht bereit gewesen ist die
Nationalhymne mitzusingen und das ist
ein sehr deutliches Zeichen und ich
würde mir manchmal mehr Zivilcourage von
Seiten der FIFA auch versprechen und
dass sie den DFB so massiv unter Druck
gesetzt hat finde ich ist unter Partnern
wenn ich das von außen bewerten darf mit
Sicherheit nicht gerade
freundschaftlich und schon gar nicht
kollegial
Rolf Mütze nicht der Vorsitzende der
SPD-Fraktion zum Haushalt zum Bürgergeld
und natürlich auch zu WM die hier auf
den Gängen zumindest natürlich auch eine
durchaus gewichtige Rolle spielt und
kontrovers diskutiert wird wir werden es
nachher noch mal hören bei Christian
Dörr von der FDP-Fraktion schauen aber
zunächst auf Bündnis 90 die Grünen hier
im Bundestag Britta Hasselmann hat hier
ihr Statement heute gemacht und sie hat
nämlich bereits bekannten Themen
natürlich auch noch mal Bezug genommen
auf die Weltklimakonferenz
in dieser Woche wird uns ganz intensiv
die Kopp und die Ergebnisse der Cop
beschäftigen wir blicken auf intensive
und sehr schwierige Verhandlungen bei
dieser großen internationalen
konferenzlicht und Schatten Hoffnung und
Frust liegen sehr eng beieinander es ist
sehr sehr wichtig dass in dieser
schwierigen Situation nicht hinter die
Ergebnisse von Paris und Glas kurz
zurückgefallen wurde es ist sehr sehr
schwierig und bedauerlich dass
insbesondere die Erdöl und erdgasstaaten
vehement weiter ihre fossilen Energien
verteidigt haben dass es sichern
schmerzlicher Punkt angesichts der da
Dramatik und der Notwendigkeit der
Bekämpfung der Klimakrise
ein positiver Aspekt ist die
Verantwortungsübernahme im Hinblick auf
die Staaten die viel haben und die den
verwundbaren Staaten nun im Rahmen eines
Klimafonds Unterstützung signalisieren
sollen also die ganzen Regelungen zu
Lost in damage und das bedeutet
natürlich jetzt für uns auf der
europäischen Ebene international diesen
klimafond auch auszuhandeln ganz
praktisch zu machen es bedeutet für uns
hier als Ampel die ambitionierten
Klimaziele die Investitionen in die
Transformation zu verstärken das alles
ist jetzt notwendig und wir sehen das
auch mit unseren Vorstellungen des
Klimaschutzprogramms was für uns noch
vorgenommen haben der Frage des
energieeffizienzgesetzes was ansteht und
den vielen Investitionen und
Gesetzesvorhaben im Bereich von Klima
und Energie dass die Bekämpfung der
Klimakrise zentrale Aufgabe der Ampel
ist und bleibt
zweites Thema
was uns in dieser Woche der
haushaltswoche des Deutschen Bundestages
beschäftigt ist selbstverständlich
die Tagung und Beratung über den
Bundeshaushalt hier nehmen wir den
Schwung der letzten Sitzungswoche mit in
der wir uns als Ampel darauf verständigt
haben und dies auch gesetzlich auf den
Weg gebracht haben als Entlastung für
Bürgerinnen und Bürger
250 € Kindergeld eine wohngeldreform die
sich in der
Strukturveränderungen gibt aber auch in
der Höhe die Frage der energiekater
Ausstieg und viele viele weitere Fragen
wie etwa das Wahlalter 16 oder die
Verankerung des kulturpasses im
Bundeshaushalt sind wichtige Akzente auf
die wir uns verständigen konnten beim
Haushalt geht es darum mehr gerecht Zeit
mehr für Klimaschutz und Transformation
und mehr für internationale
Zusammenarbeit und Verantwortung im
Bereich der Entwicklungszusammenarbeit
der humanitären Hilfe zu leisten dass
alles ist uns durch die Haushaltsplan
Beratung in den Fachausschüssen gelungen
und wird diese Woche sicher dann im
Deutschen Bundestag auch beraten und
beschlossen werden und der dritte und
letzte Punkt selbstverständlich hoffen
wir dass wir in dieser Woche zu einem
Ergebnis in Sachen Bürgergeld kommen das
Bürgergeld ist eine wichtige
Sozialreform im Interesse der
betroffenen Menschen ist es notwendig
im Vermittlungsausschuss am Mittwoch und
dann im Bundestag und Bundesrat zu einer
gemeinsamen Auffassung zu kommen im
Interesse der betroffenen Menschen steht
für uns der klare Akzent auf Ermutigung
und Hilfe und Unterstützung im Fokus das
ist notwendig und darauf warten
betroffene Menschen und ich bin ganz
zuversichtlich dass uns das gelingen
wird denn es ist im Interesse vieler
Familien vieler Betroffener die darauf
warten dass sich hier etwas tut und eine
Veränderung im Bürgergeld verankert wird
das Bürgergeld wird kommen da bin ich
mir ganz sicher
haushaltswoche das bmwk hat jetzt
bestätigt dass die lng-terminals
deutlich teurer werden sollen wir sind
bei glaube ich über 6 Milliarden
Gesamtbedarf kommt das schon eine große
Menge kommt dass sie sich überraschend
oder worin begründet sich das jetzt
diese hohe Zahl zu hören und was heißt
das aus ihrer Sicht mit Blick auf die
Planungen also
hoffen dass es vielleicht doch nicht
alles gebraucht viel davon Puffer ist
oder doch noch mal genauer prüfen ob das
der richtige Weg ist nein also ich
glaube an der Grundsatzentscheidung gibt
es hier gar keinen Fall tun dass es
sinnvoll und notwendig ist im Rahmen der
Vorsorge was die Frage
Versorgungssicherheit
angeht in dieser energiekrisenzeit
eben den Bau der LG Terminals
voranzutreiben in diesem sehr kurzen
Verfahren und der kurzfristigen Arzt ist
jetzt mit deutlich höheren Zahlen
offenbar zu rechnen wenn das der Fall
ist wird mit der Haushaltsausschuss und
wird die Bundesregierung dafür Sorge
tragen dass es daran nicht scheitert da
bin ich mir ganz sicher denn das
übergeordnete Ziel ist die
Versorgungssicherheit und wir wollen
eben auf verschiedenen Ebenen hier eine
Absicherung haben und dazu gehören an
dieser Stelle in dieser krisenhaften
Zeit auch die lng-terminals
Britta hasselwagenvorsitzende der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen im
Deutschen Bundestag am Ende noch mal zu
den Terminals für Flüssiggas Importe in
Norddeutschland die ihren Kosten sich
ähm ja zumindest verdoppelt haben
bislang war die Bundesregierung stolz
darauf die Planungszeiten radikal
verkürzt zu haben für solche
terminalsspalter sagen inzwischen
Planungszeiten halbiert Kosten
verdoppelt wir schauen mal wie das Ganze
weitergeht und blicken als nächstes auf
das Statement von Christian dürr dem
Vorsitzenden der FDP-Fraktion der hat in
seinen Äußerung vor allem darauf
abgehoben dass es viele Investitionen
viele Milliarden an Investitionen im
neuen Haushalt für 2023 geben wird große
Entlastung für die Bevölkerung und vor
allem dass die Schuldenbremse
eingehalten wird
wir schaffen mit diesem Bundeshaushalt
rekordinvestitionen für Deutschland
insgesamt
71,5 Milliarden Euro und damit 20
Milliarden Euro mehr als in vergangenen
Jahr und schieben damit ganz wichtige
Zukunftsprojekte an wie beispielsweise
die gesetzliche aktienrente das Thema
planungsbeschleunigung ist uns besonders
wichtig Einwanderung oder auch das Thema
Bafög was wir mit diesem hohen
Bundeshaushalt absichern werden als
zweites schaffen wir mit diesem
Bundeshaushalt auch eine Rekord
Entlastung insbesondere für die hart
arbeitende Mitte in Deutschland für die
Familien von insgesamt 50 Milliarden
Euro bei den Steuern und beim Kindergeld
das ist gerade in diesen schwierigen
Zeiten glaube ich eine sehr wichtige
Botschaft dass wir dort den
Inflationsausgleich durchsetzen und
direkte Entlastung bei den Menschen in
Deutschland erreichen und als drittes
ist es und in einem Krisen geprägten
Jahr gelungen die Schuldenbremse für den
Bundeshaushalt einzuhalten und
gleichzeitig krisenbeding Ausgaben
solide zu finanzieren wir reduzieren die
Neuverschuldung für das Jahr 2023
gegenüber dem aktuellen Jahr um zwei
Drittel und helfen gezielt über den
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds sie
wissen dass wir derzeit an einer
gaspreisbremse arbeiten die zum
kommenden Jahr kommen soll und an einer
strompreisbremse auch das ist in diesen
Zeiten ein sehr wichtiges Signal die
Zinsen werden sich im kommenden Haushalt
gegenüber dem Jahr 2021 fast zehnfachen
die Zinsausgaben des Bundes und das
zeigt die wichtig es ist dass wir für
den Haushalt die Schuldenbremse
einhalten das ist aus meiner Sicht
keinen Anliegen nur der FDP sondern es
ist im Interesse aller Menschen in
Deutschland und insbesondere der
zukünftige Generation die wir nicht mit
weiteren Schulden und weiteren
Zinsbelastungen belasten wollen die
Schuldenbremse auszusetzen könnten wir
uns nicht länger leisten ich will das an
der Stelle deutlich sagen und die
Schuldenbremse für alles mögliche
auszusetzen wie es manche in letzten
Monaten sich vorgestellt haben ist nicht
finanzierbar und deswegen ist es richtig
dass wir zur Schuldenbremse für den
Haushalt 2023
zurückkehren und das dritte Thema war
dass ich sprechen möchte ist das Thema
Bürgergeld da laufen ja zurzeit die
Verhandlungen im Rahmen des
Vermittlungsverfahrens zwischen
Bundestag und Bundesrat und ich will an
der Stelle noch mal eines feststellen
die seinerzeitige sozialstaatsreform mit
der Einführung des Arbeitslosengeldes 2
also von Hartz IV stößt mittlerweile an
ihre Grenzen wir stellen fest dass es
nicht mehr dazu beiträgt dass Menschen
aus der Arbeitslosigkeit in den
Arbeitsmarkt eintreten sondern sie
teilweise sogar vom Arbeitsmarkt
ferngehalten werden weil die
Arbeitsanreize insbesondere beim
Hinzuverdienst nicht mehr funktionieren
und deswegen ist das Bürgergeld uns ein
wichtiges Anliegen die eine Seite ist
die Erhöhung der Regelsätze da gibt es
ja Konsens zwischen Koalition und
Position aber wichtig ist uns die
strukturelle Veränderung insbesondere
bei den hinzuverdienstregeln die
Arbeitsanreize zu erhöhen denn Hartz IV
funktioniert heute nicht mehr und
deswegen müssen wir das Fordern und
Fördern auf neue Beine stellen und es
schaffen das ist hier mehr
Arbeitsanreize gibt deswegen würde ich
mich freuen wenn auch das ein Teil des
vermittlungsergebnisses am Ende ist dass
dieser Kern des Bürgergeldes dieser Kern
dieser sozialstaatsreform erhalten
bleibt weil es ein besonderes Anliegen
einerseits meiner Fraktion meiner Partei
war aber zum anderen insbesondere für
all diejenigen die auffordern und
fördern setzen auf Arbeitsanreize setzen
diejenigen müsste es nicht nur
zufriedenstellen sondern insbesondere zu
einer Zustimmung bewegen und ich will an
der Stelle eines sagen wenn wir wie es
teilweise die Union in den letzten Tagen
und Wochen gefordert hat lediglich die
Regelsätze erhöhen ohne aber die
Hinzuverdienstgrenzen anzupassen und
damit die Arbeitsanreize zu erhöhen dann
wäre an der Stelle aus meiner Sicht
nichts gewonnen und es wäre keine echte
Reform mit der FDP-Fraktion wird es eine
Reform geben nur wenn Arbeitsanreize
auch gestärkt werden eine alleinige
Erhöhung der Regelsätze kann es aus
meiner Sicht deshalb nicht geben und das
letzte Thema was ich kurz ansprechen
möchte insbesondere weil es die
medienlage der letzten Tage noch einmal
bestimmt hat mit dem Eröffnungsspiel
gestern in Katar ist die Weltmeister die
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft man muss an
dieser Stelle nochmal eines ganz klar
sagen die Vergabe der
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft an kataver im
Nachhinein ein absoluter Fehler der FIFA
das hat sich ja nicht nur in den letzten
Jahren schon raus kristallisiert sondern
jetzt wo die WM gestartet ist wird es
vor allem Menschen noch einmal mehr
sichtbar für diese Fehlentscheidung des
Fußball Weltverbandes kann allerdings
unsere Nationalmannschaft nicht und
deswegen drücken wir natürlich dem Team
vom Hand sie fliegt in diesen Tagen für
ein gutes Turnier die Daumen der Sport
und die Einhaltung von Menschenrechten
lässt sich nicht trennen das muss man in
aller Kleid sagen und ich hoffe dass
auch nach dieser
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft die Debatte
über die Vergabe von Großereignissen von
Sport Großereignissen wie
Weltmeisterschaften nicht abreißen wird
und das Präsidium der FDP hat heute
morgen ja ein entsprechende Beschluss
gefasst dass die Vergabe solche
Ereignisse in Zukunft auch an
demokratische und
Menschenrechtsstandards gebunden werden
sollte Stichwort vergabekodex das ist
aus meiner Sicht eine sehr gute Idee die
ich auch als Fraktion unterstütze
der FDP-Fraktionsvorsitzende Christian
dürr mit seiner Sicht auf dem
Bundeshaushalt 2023 und ja dass man es
seiner Meinung nach kaum besser lösen
kann als die Koalition das gemacht hat
kritiker werfen der Koalition vor
Schattenhaushalte zu führen insbesondere
die sonderschuld für die Bundeswehr aber
auch den sogenannten
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds aus dem
dann die Entlastung kommen sollen für
Bürgerinnen und Bürger kleine und
mittlere Unternehmen bei den
Energiekosten über Gas und Wärme
beispielsweise aber auch beim Strom wir
schauen auf die afd-fraktion im
Deutschen Bundestag die heute ein
weiteres Mitglied weniger zu beklagen
hat denn Johanna Kota ist sowohl aus der
Partei als auch aus der Fraktion
ausgetreten ihr Mandat will sie
allerdings behalten was zu einigermaßen
und Zufriedenheit der der
Koalitionsspitze führt wir hören
kinopala und Alice Weidel unter anderem
auch zu diesem Thema
der Klimagipfel liegt hinter uns die
bundesaußenministerin ist enttäuscht
dass kein anderes Land ein Sonderweg von
Deutschland mitgehen möchte und zwar den
gleichzeitigen Ausstieg aus fossiler
Energie als auch der Kernenergie
forcieren möchte und
da sieht man einmal mehr
wie weit die deutsche Bundesregierung
eigentlich schon weg ist von jeglichem
Realität sind wie ein Industriestaat so
betrieben wird wir hatten das schon
vielfach und dementsprechend gibt es dem
auch nichts hinzuzufügen ich frage mich
allerdings was solche Mammut Konferenzen
sollen wo sich Menschen einfinden zwei
Wochen lang herumzusitzen und irgendwie
dummes Zeug zu debattieren das möchte
ich hier ganz klar sagen dass
führt zu nichts ein Weltklima Ziel von
1,5 Grad ist auch durch nichts gestützt
und dementsprechend auch genauso
irrational wie die Politik die in
Deutschland vollzogen wird es geht aber
da das haben wir auch gesehen und was
ganz anderes durch die Etablierung des
Entschädigungsfonds ist ein riesiger
umverteilungsfonds etabliert worden
der fernab von jeglicher Definition von
Kriterien ein Riesentopf für
Umverteilung und subventionens
Geschacher
eben etabliert wurde zum anderen sehen
wir natürlich in Deutschland die
aktuellen wirklichen Probleme am
Wochenende hat ja bereits der Präsident
des Bundesamt für Bevölkerungsschutz und
Katastrophenhilfe Ralf Thiesler darauf
aufmerksam gemacht und auch auf eine
Gefahr von Blackouts in Deutschland
hingewiesen die natürlich im Winter
passieren können genau das haben wir und
davon haben wir immer gewarnt jetzt
macht sich das mittlerweile auch am
prominenter Stelle bemerkbar nach
wahrscheinlich politischen Druck ist er
wieder zurückgerudert aber
nichtsdestotrotz sehen wir ja die
darüber gestritten wird wie der Kollaps
im Stromnetz jetzt wahrscheinlich im
Winter doch anstehen könnte und hier
muss es natürlich auch darum gehen dass
hier Konzepte für den Katastrophenfall
von der Bundesregierung auch erstellt
werden so wie wir es im übrigen auch in
unserem Positionspapier da
Bundestagsfraktion gefordert haben dass
Deutschland Energieversorgung endlich
wieder auch einer festen Grundlagen
und auch nicht auf einer Grundlage
gestellt wird das fordern wir wir wollen
deswegen das hier weiter intensiv an der
Kernenergie geforscht wird und dass die
Kernenergie natürlich auch als Träger
der zukünftigen Energie in Deutschland
weitere Priorität hat dass die
Kernkraftwerke am Netz bleiben dass man
die natürlich auch perspektivisch
ausbauen muss das gleiche gilt für
nordstream 1 und 2 dass diese Apparat
repariert gesichert werden und wieder
ans Netz kommen denn deutschland braucht
eine zuverlässige Gasversorgung das ist
absolut wichtig das wäre im Übrigen auch
für die Verbraucher das wichtige Signal
auch für die Mittelstand um diese
Energiekrise auch zu verhindern und
damit verhindern wir nämlich den Block
out in Blackout in Deutschland den Ruin
unserer Wirtschaft und auch die
Vernichtung unseres Wohlstandes der
deutschen Bürger deswegen muss eine
Vergrößerung des energieangebotes
oberste Priorität haben das sind die
wirklichen Probleme in Deutschland nicht
über die kleinteiligen über die wir
teilweise öffentlich groß diskutieren
[Musik]
hat heute morgen ihren Austritt aus
Fraktion und aus Partei erklärt und das
unter anderem damit begründet
es seien zu viele rote Linien
überschritten worden zum Beispiel durch
ich zitiere die Anbiederung an Regime
wie Russland China oder Iran was sagen
sie dazu
natürlich jeder Grundlage und das sind
auch vorgeschoben aus meiner Sicht
vorgeschobene Argumente Frau Kutta hat
sich schon über das letzte Jahr extrem
stark
entfremdet und war auch nicht mehr ein
sage ich jetzt mal ein ein positiver
Vermögenswert innerhalb der Fraktion und
dementsprechend hat sich das schon
abgezeichnet
ich glaube das sogar der der Austritt
aus Partei und aus der Fraktion viel zu
spät kam ich hätte es deutlich früher
erwartet und ähm ich finde es auch nicht
vollgerichtig dass Frau Kota ihr Mann da
hat was sie über die afd-ehrungen hat
behält sie sollte es abgeben
noch weitere Fragen
ja noch mal zum Thema kurtar jetzt an
Herrn koopalla Frau couta schreibt in
ihrer Pressemitteilung auch davon
es habe es gebe einen dauer-mobbing in
der Partei im Kampf um Posten und es
gäbe korrupte Netzwerke können Sie mal
erklären was sie damit meinen könnte ja
wir müssen sie schon Frau carta selber
fragen was sie damit meint ich kenne
keine Netzwerke die in diese Richtung
gehen das ist in der Politik teilweise
ein bisschen haarschuh geht das können
wir beide als Spitzenkandidaten zur
Bundestagswahl gern bestätigen und daran
hat die Frau total an damals beteiligt
also von daher das müssen Sie schon
selber fragen
und Alice Weidel und die beiden sind
natürlich die Fraktionsspitzen der AFD
und nicht Koalitionsspitzen wie ich eben
aus Versehen gesagt habe der Rest steht
für sich bei diesem Statement vor der
Sitzung der afd-fraktion wir schauen
noch auf die fraktions-sitzung der
linken bzw das Statement von Amira
Mohammed Ali dazu die mit dem
Bundeshaushalt 2023 so gar nicht
einverstanden ist
dieser Haushalt ist leider völlig aus
der Zeit gefallen es finden sich keine
Antworten zu den großen
Herausforderungen unserer Zeit und die
Herausforderung sind eben dass wir die
Situation haben dass die Schere zwischen
arm und reichen unserem Land immer
weiter auseinander klafft immer mehr
Bevölkerung Schichten bis weit in die
Mittelschichten hinein haben die
Menschen Existenzängste und Nöte dagegen
geschieht praktisch nichts wir haben es
ja verlautbaren lassen oder die
Regierung hat verlautbaren lassen dass
solche wichtigen Dinge wie eine
Strompreis ein Strompreis Deckel dir der
längst angekündigt war dass das
vielleicht im März kommt Gaspreis Deckel
Gaspreis Bremse soll auch erst im März
kommen also nach der Heizperiode die
Höhe ist ungewiss nach dem Plänen der
Bundesregierung wird das aber für viele
immer noch viel zu teuer sein und im
Haushalt findet sich eben nichts um das
vernünftig ab zu federn
was ist dringend bräuchte wären ganz
konkrete Initiativen wir sagen zum
Beispiel wir wollen 5 Milliarden Euro
und die sozialen Wohnungsbau
voranzubringen weil natürlich
bezahlbarer Wohnraum ist nach wie vor
ein großes Thema es ist viel zu wenig
davon vorhanden wir brauchen unbedingt
in der jetzigen Situation mehr für die
Mehrheit die Bürgerinnen und Bürger die
von diesen Teuerungen betroffen sind
darunter leiden die brauchen
Unterstützung es braucht höhere
Direktzahlungen dafür brauchen wir Geld
und dieses Geld kann man auch zwei Wegen
bekommen einmal ist es dringend
notwendig ist eine gerechte
Vermögenssteuer einzuführen ich meine
SPD und Grüne haben damit noch zur
Bundestagswahl Wahlwerbung gemacht jetzt
plötzlich ist davon keine Rede mehr
man ist der Meinung oder man könnte der
Meinung sein SPD und Grüne haben die
Haltung was schert mich mein Geschwätz
von gestern wenn es jetzt bloß den
Koalitionsfrieden erhält das geht aber
nicht es geht nicht dass Sie sich hier
an der Stelle der FDP auf dieser Art und
Weise unterordnen denn wenn es jetzt
nicht Zeit ist für eine Vermögenssteuer
ja wann denn bitte dann außerdem haben
wir als LINKE im Bundestag beantragt
dass wir eben zu Bewältigung der Krise
das ist jetzt Zeit ist eine einmalige
Vermögensabgabe zu erheben für
Multimillionäre und Milliardäre das
würde ganz konkrete einnehmen und Namen
generieren leider ist es abgelehnt
worden auch das ist verantwortungslos
genauso wie das 100 Milliarden Euro
Sondervermögen für die Bundeswehr das ja
sogar im Grundgesetz steht es wird so am
Haushalt vorbei geschummelt in einem
Schattenhaushalt findet das Platz das
ist nichts weiter als ja Irreführung der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger und es kann nicht
sein dass auf der einen Seite für die
Aufrüstung mal eben über Nacht 100
Milliarden Euro zur Verfügung gestellt
worden sind wenn es aber darum geht die
Bevölkerung zu entlasten wenn es darum
geht dass die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
Unterstützung bekommen auch das die
Wirtschaft Unterstützung bekommt dann
wird immer gehadert und gerungen und
diskutiert und debattiert um jeden Euro
und um jeden Cent und das kann einfach
nicht angehen die Bundesregierung legt
sich selbst Fesseln an was den Haushalt
angeht einmal weil sie eben darauf
verzichten endlich eine Vermögenssteuer
einzuführen aber eben auch weil an der
Schuldenbremse weiter festgehalten wird
für Sondervermögen Bundeswehr gab es
seine Ausnahme das konnte dann an der
Schuldenbremse vorbei ja aufgenommen
werden für alles andere soll sie jetzt
weiterhin gelten und da muss ich sagen
auch hier ist es einfach ein Skandal
dass die SPD und auch die Grünen sich
hier von der FDP auf dieser Art und
Weise ihre Politik diktieren lassen denn
die Schuldenbremse
ist in die jetzigen Zeit einfach
unvernünftig es wäre dringend notwendig
dass man entsprechende
Handlungsfreiheiten hat um die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger zu unterstützen
aber eben auch um die Wirtschaft wirksam
zu unterstützen wir wissen dass
deutschland droht vom
Industriestandort zum Industriemuseum zu
werden hier braucht es mutiges Handeln
der Regierung leider finden wir es nicht
Stichwort mutiges Handeln das Bürgergeld
ist alles andere als ein mutiges Handeln
der Bundesregierung es ist eine leichte
Verbesserung zu Hartz IV ist es gerade
einmal minimal oder
Nennwert der Inflationsausgleich mit der
Steigerung von 53 Euro und man muss
sagen was der jetzt gerade in den
bundesländerberatung stattfindet ist
wirklich ein erbärmliche
Schmierentheater und das muss Enden es
ist wirklich ein Armutszeugnis dass die
ampelparteien und die Union sich nicht
mal auf diese minimalen Verbesserungen
für Hartz IV Betroffene einigen können
das muss dringend kommen aber es bleibt
dabei
das Bürgergeld ist keine Abkehr vom
falschen Hartz-IV-System es ist immer
noch Armut per Gesetz denn auch mit
diesen 53 Euro mehr ist es nicht so dass
die Menschen die davon betroffen sind
ein Leben in Würde führen können im
Gegenteil im Gegenteil ist es immer noch
viel zu wenig um davon leben zu können
und wenn die CDU sich jetzt hinstellt um
die Menschen im potenziellen
bürgergeldbezug gegen diejenigen
auszuspielen versucht die Mindestlohn
arbeiten und sagt das ist Abstand ist zu
klein es gibt keine Anreize mehr
arbeiten zu gehen weil dann gebe ich das
Bürgergeld zu hoch sei dann muss ich
sagen ja dann liebe Union stellt euch
doch an unsere Seite und kämpft für ein
höheren Mindestlohn und insgesamt für
höhere Löhne das Heil ist doch nicht
darin zu sehen dass man das Leben für
diejenigen die von Sozialleistungen
abhängig sind immer schwerer macht und
im Grunde genommen dafür sorgt dass
diese Menschen gar nicht mehr existieren
können nein es ist der richtige Weg ist
es Sozialleistung zu haben die einen
normalen Lebensstandard ermöglichen und
eben Löhne zu haben die einen gutes
Leben ermöglichen das ist eigentlich das
Mindeste was ist bräuchte
Amira Mohammed Ali Vorsitzende der
Linksfraktion im Deutschen Bundestag mit
ihrer Sicht auf diese Woche und den
Bundeshaushalt 2023 die Linken haben
heute den Anfang gemacht um 14 Uhr sind
sie schon zusammengekommen zu ihrer
Fraktionssitzung den Abschluss bildet
sozusagen die SPD heute die kommen
nämlich erst um 18 Uhr zu ihren
Beratungen zusammen beschäftigen sich
aber auch wie alle anderen mit dem
Bundeshaushalt 2023 der wird
476 Milliarden Euro umfassen davon dafür
müssen 45,6 Milliarden neue Schulden
aufgenommen werden das ist der reguläre
Haushalt Unternehmen gibt es halt die
sonderethas für die Bundeswehr über 100
Milliarden und dann noch mal fast 200
Milliarden für den Wirtschaft
stabilisierungsform darüber redet morgen
um 9:45 Uhr gehört Joachim von verlor
auf der plenarsaalleben des Bundestages
mitgesehene löt der
haushaltspolitischen Sprecherin der
Linksfraktion und mit Otto Fricke dem
hausarztpolitischen Sprecher der
FDP-Fraktion der sollten Sie nicht
verpassen denn da kriegen sie einen
schönen Überblick über das was dann ab
zehn im Bundestag passiert in der
Finanzminister diesen Etat seinen Etat
dann noch einmal vorstellt das sollte
wie gesagt sehen und wir verabschieden
uns an dieser Stelle von der
Fraktionsebene im Bundestag und sagen
sie sollten auch sehen Phoenix der Tag